the second half of 2018 will begin with
the annual state of the European address
Commission President jean-claude Juncker
will outline the EU s-- priorities and
challenges before the 2019 European
elections migration climate change
growth security the EU is facing many
challenges Parliament's debates on the
future of Europe will continue with six
more EU leaders another challenge is to
update you copyright rules members want
to ensure fair pay for artists and
journalists for their work online while
respecting the needs of online users the
proposals will be on September's plenary
agenda better protection of children
online stricter rules for video on
demand and for TV advertising are among
proposals to be discussed members are
pushing to improve access to the
Internet and lower the cost of
long-distance intra EU phone calls they
also proposed a reverse one-one-two
system to allow authorities to alert
citizens to emergencies much like in the
first half of the year environmental
concern we'll continue to talk
Parliament's agenda by 2030 at least 32
percent of EU energy consumption shows
stem from renewable sources Parliament
will also review plans to curb the use
of antibiotics in farm animals
the new rules aim to keep drug-resistant
bacteria out of the human food chain and
reduce the environmental impacts members
will vote to create a new European
solidarity core giving young people the
opportunity to volunteer for projects
helping communities across the EU in
November the Luke's film prize will go
to a European film the prize is awarded
annually to a film that contributes to a
discussion on a social or political
issue the 2018 Sakharov Prize for
freedom of thoughts will honour human
rights defenders in December
[Music]